Although this example may appear to be
abstract, it is actually quite realistic
because it is similar to many
real world APT instances.
In this example, the CEO gets
an email with a PDF attachment
showing pie charts of sales activities.
When he opens the PDF document
inside browser, for example, so
that he can use the Acrobat Reader
plug in to view the document,
the crafted attack data embedded in the
PDF document would cause a zero exploit
that broke out the plug in sand box in
a browser and compromised the browser.
In a detail of such attack can be for
example a buffer overflow attack that
lead to control flow hijacking and
taking over the browser.
Then the injected attack code will
download a malicious browser extension.
Record that a malicious browser
extension is the malware embedded within
the browser.
>From this point on, each time the CEO
send an email to his employees
with an attachment, for
example a PDF document,
the malicious browser extension
would infect the attachments.
Eventually, the malware gets
on the computer of a user
who has admin privilege of
the company's server, and
therefore the malware can
steal the credentials
that will lead the malware into
access into the companies servers.
>From this point on,
the malware can then steal the most
valuable data from the company.
This example captures a number
of key characteristics of APTs.
Fist, the users, including the system
admins do not realize that
their computers and
their network have been compromised.
Second, the APT activities blend
in with normal user activity.
For example, the APT does not
just send email by itself,
it only modifies emails sent by the CEO.
Third, it takes its time in or
to get to the key individual and
steal his credentials.